I'm working on a novel it is a story of
my life and my sisters make it short and
spicy and if the main character is a
girl make sure she's married by the end
Wow I want to be an artist in Rome and
be the best painter in the wor us what
you want to isn't a Joe to be a famous
writer yes but it sounds so crass when
she says
a way of getting into mischief so do I
this is Meg Amy Beth and Joe I intend to
make my own way in the world no one
makes their own way
least of all a woman you'll need to
marry well you are not married not well
that's because I'm rich Joe would you
like to dance with me I can't because I
scorched my dress and you Meg told me to
keep still so no one would see it I have
ad about humanity
Joe is a lost cause
[Music]
that's you are your family's hope now
I believe we have some power over who we
love it isn't something that just
happens to a person
and I think the poets night to sue
Murray we can leave right now I'll sell
stories John you here should be an
actress and you should have a life on
the stage just because my dreams are
different than yours doesn't mean
they're unimportant new play written by
Miss Jo March
women they have minds and they have
souls as well as just hearts I want to
be great or nothing and they've got
ambition and they've got talent as well
as just beauty I'm so sick of people
saying that love is just all of them in
that's it for I'm so sick of it
[Music]
there are some nature's - laughing - man
so who does she marry
[Music]
[Applause]